Je me souviens très bien : une des toutes
premières fois que je suis sorti avec lui
— il y a grosso modo 10 ans — j’ai croisé
un autre propriétaire de chien, qui m’a
demandé le prénom du mien.
J’ai répondu « Haristote ».
Mais là, l’autre propriétaire a dit : « Ah,
comme le mari de Jacqueline Kennedy ».
En fait, il voulait parler d’Aristote…
Onassis.
C’était un milliardaire grec avec lequel
la femme du président américain John Fitzgerald
Kennedy s’était remariée après le fameux
assassinat de 1963.
La remarque du propriétaire de chien m’a
comme paralysé.
Sur le moment, j’ai eu la flemme de commencer
une explication.
Mais j’avais envie de répondre : « Non,
c’est pas lui, le grand Aristote ! »
Le grand Aristote n’est pas un milliardaire
du XXe siècle, mais un philosophe grec du
IVe siècle avant J.-C.
Et pas n’importe quel philosophe grec…
Il est le dernier des trois plus grands noms
de la pensée de la Grèce antique : Socrate,
qui a été le maître de Platon, lequel a
été le maître d’Aristote.
Comme pour Platon, à propos duquel j’ai
déjà publié une vidéo, il y a peu de sources
fiables sur la vie d’Aristote — et il
y a encore moins d’informations.
Ma principale source, ce sont les Vies et
doctrines des philosophes illustres de Diogène
Laërce (livre qui est la référence pour
les biographies des penseurs de l’Antiquité).
Encore une fois, ce n’est pas une biographie
de 800 pages sur Aristote — MAIS le peu
de choses qu’on apprend sont très intéressantes.
Non seulement Aristote a eu un destin exceptionnel,
mais vous allez voir que ce destin nous permet
de comprendre beaucoup de choses sur la manière
dont le monde fonctionne encore aujourd’hui.
Je vais donc partager avec vous 10 anecdotes
étonnantes et révélatrices sur la vie d’Aristote.
Vous allez voir que la toute dernière est
particulièrement surprenante : elle concerne
le lien mystérieux entre la mort d’Aristote
et celle de Socrate, 77 ans plus tôt.
Quand on pense à la xénophobie, on imagine
spontanément que ce sont des individus d’autres
continents, d’autres civilisations, qui
en sont victimes.
Eh bien non, les préjugés ne comptent pas
les kilomètres !
L’être humain est un animal tribal, donc
il est capable d’être raciste avec l’habitant
du village d’à-côté.
Et Aristote en a fait l’expérience.
Contrairement eux deux autres géants de la
pensée grecque, Socrate et Platon, Aristote
n’est pas né à Athènes.
Il est originaire de Stagire, un village du
nord-est de la Grèce actuelle. C’est une
très vieille colonie ionienne qui avait été
l’alliée d’Athènes, dont elle est distante
de seulement 500km.
En quoi cette anecdote est-elle révélatrice
?
Eh bien Aristote est ce qu’on appelle un
« métèque » à Athènes.
Ce terme français, « métèque », vient
du grec metoikos, qui signifie « étranger
».
Et son origine, Aristote ne peut pas la faire
oublier. Quand il vient vivre à Athènes
vers 17-18 ans, il est surnommé « le Stagirite
», et les Athéniens se méfient de lui.
20 ans plus tard, à la mort de Platon, Aristote
apparaît comme son successeur naturel.
En effet, malgré leurs désaccords intellectuels,
Aristote était le disciple préféré, le
principal assistant, et Platon l’appelait
même « l’intelligence de l’école ».
Mais voilà… l’Académie ne peut pas être
dirigée par un métèque !
On oublie souvent une chose quand on parle
de philosophie : on ne peut pas philosopher,
se poser et réfléchir librement, si le frigo
est vide.
Eh oui, il y a une hiérarchie des besoins,
comme l’explique la fameuse pyramide de
Maslow.
Donc se consacrer à la philosophie, c’est
un privilège.
Ça m’a frappé en lisant les biographies
des philosophes de l’Antiquité de Diogène
Laërce : ce sont tous des fils de bonnes
familles, d’aristocrates, de grands propriétaires
terriens ou de riches marchands !
Le schéma qui revient souvent, c’est qu’ils
décident d’intégrer une école philosophique
à l’adolescence, tout frais payé par leur
famille.
Alors bien sûr, il y a des exceptions — Socrate
étant la plus célèbre — mais ce sont
des exceptions.
Aristote, lui, ne fait pas exception : il
est le fils d’un médecin qui est l’ami
personnel (en plus d’en être le médecin)
du roi de Macédoine, Amyntas III de Macédoine
(le grand père d’Alexandre le Grand).
En clair, Aristote naît avec les 3 capitaux
au sens de Bourdieu.
Il a le capital économique, puisque sa famille
vit dans l’aisance financière.
Il a le capital social, puisque le père d’Aristote
a un puissant réseau politique à travers
son amitié avec le roi de Macédoine.
Enfin, Aristote a aussi le capital culturel,
car son père l’élève dans l’atmosphère
de la médecine — d’ailleurs la mère
est sage-femme (comme celle de Socrate) — et
Aristote baigne plus largement dans la science
au cours de son enfance.
D’ailleurs, c’est certainement cette éducation
qui explique l’originalité de l’esprit
d’Aristote, son ouverture, sa rigueur empirique,
et même son pragmatisme (je trouve).
Certains biographes disent qu’il est médecin
comme son père, et qu’il prescrit des remèdes
à ses connaissances. Une légende fait même
de lui le petit-fils d’Asclépios, le dieu
de la médecine.
Il passe énormément de temps sur des îles
en dehors d’Athènes à collecter des échantillons
pour étudier les animaux et les plantes.
Il théorise le fonctionnement du vivant,
au point certains font de lui le fondateur
de la biologie.
Quand on pense à un philosophe, on n’imagine
pas un bodybuilder — ni même un guerrier.
On se dit qu’un philosophe dévalorise le
corps, puisqu’il valorise l’esprit ; et
qu’il dévalorise la violence physique,
puisqu’il valorise la réflexion et le dialogue.
Alors, ce n’est pas toujours vrai.
Par exemple, Socrate et Platon étaient tous
les deux des hommes forts (particulièrement
Platon), et ils se sont illustrés à la guerre
(le courage de Socrate est légendaire).
Aristote, lui, colle bien mieux à l’image
qu’on se fait d’un philosophe.
Il est assez faible physiquement : il est
petit ; il a des jambes très maigres ; la
voix faible et de petits yeux (contrairement
à Socrate, dont les grands yeux fascinaient
ses interlocuteurs).
Que tirer de l’apparence physique d’Aristote
?
Eh bien Aristote n’est pas, comme Platon,
un homme qui en impose par son physique ; il
n’est pas non plus un homme charismatique
comme Socrate.
Donc on ne le remarque pas spontanément.
Comment se faire remarquer si on n’est pas
grand, pas costaud, et qu’on n’est pas
non plus charismatique ?
Alors vous avez peut-être envie de me dire
: Aristote est super intelligent, ça suffit
pour se faire remarquer.
Oui, mais l’intelligence, ce n’est pas
instantanée.
Ça ne CAPTE pas l’attention comme la taille,
la musculature ou le charisme.
Donc Aristote compense sa faiblesse physique
et son absence de charisme… par le style.
Au point que les gens de l’époque le lui
reprochent : il est toujours vêtu avec recherche
; il porte des bagues et des anneaux ; il
a les cheveux courts et… il se rase !
Ça le fait vraiment sortir du lot, parce
que la barbe est un symbole de virilité et
de sagesse dans la Grèce antique (on peut
même aller en prison pour avoir coupé la
barbe d’un autre homme !).
En quoi cette anecdote est-elle révélatrice
?
Eh bien elle révèle qu’Aristote, contrairement
à beaucoup de philosophes de l’époque
(Platon le premier) — Aristote n’est pas
un ascète.
C’est-à-dire qu’il ne cherche pas à
faire des efforts héroïques de discipline
pour acquérir la force et la fermeté du
caractère. Il ne cherche pas à supprimer
le désir en lui ; il ne s’inflige pas des
souffrances.
D’ailleurs, on le lui reproche, de ne pas
incarner la figure du philosophe qui est au-dessus
des plaisirs de la vie matérielle : il collectionnerait
la vaisselle, ce qui serait preuve de sa gourmandise
; il adorerait les bains d’huile, ce qui
serait preuve de sa mollesse ; et il revendrait
même l’huile utilisée pour ses bains,
ce qui serait preuve de son avarice.
Je sais que ça se fait de nos jours, mais
j’ai du mal à croire qu’Aristote faisait
ça.
Après, si on met de côté les caricatures,
son mode de vie est tout de même conforme
à sa théorie de la sagesse.
Parce qu’en effet, pour Aristote, la sagesse,
ça consiste à conserver LA JUSTE MESURE
dans les passions et les actions.
« Tout homme instruit et raisonnable ne cherche
que le juste milieu » écrit-il dans son
Éthique à Nicomaque.
Pendant mes études, j’ai donné beaucoup
de cours de culture générale.
Et du coup, quand j’ai terminé mes études,
j’ai eu l’idée de créer une entreprise
qui mette en relation des adolescents avec
des étudiants pour qu’ils les guident et
les accompagnent dans le développement de
leur culture générale.
L’idée, c’était que l’étudiant joue
un peu le rôle d’un grand-frère brillant
qui stimule l’intérêt et l’ambition
de l’adolescent, et qui lui fasse gagner
en maturité.
Et cette entreprise, je l’avais baptisée…
« Aristote & Alexandre ».
Pourquoi ce nom ?
Parce qu’Aristote a été le précepteur
du légendaire conquérant Alexandre le Grand.
Quand Aristote a 41 ans, le roi Philippe II
de Macédoine le fait venir pour qu’il s’occupe
de l’éducation de son fils de 13 ans, Alexandre.
Pendant deux ans, Aristote lui enseigne tout
ce qu’il sait (et à l’époque, il est
déjà une véritable encyclopédie vivante).
Mais la relation dépasse largement du cadre
de l’enseignement : Aristote devient un
ami, et même plus, UN SECOND PÈRE pour le
jeune Alexandre.
« L’un lui a donné la vie, l’autre lui
a appris à vivre » dit Plutarque dans sa
biographie d’Alexandre (à propos de Philippe,
le père, et d’Aristote, le précepteur).
Le lien qui unit Aristote et Alexandre est
si fort que le philosophe reste encore plusieurs
années auprès de son élève lorsque celui-devient
régent de Macédoine à 15 ans.
Que retenir de cette anecdote ?
Elle est un des plus célèbres exemples de
la relation entre le savoir et le pouvoir.
Parce que beaucoup de gens penseront, comme
le général de Gaulle, qu’il n’y aurait
pas eu Alexandre le Grand… sans le grand
Aristote.
« La véritable école du commandement est
la culture générale. Au fond des victoires
d'Alexandre, on retrouve toujours Aristote.
», écrit de Gaulle dans Vers l’armée
de métier.
L’idée qu’illustre la relation entre
Aristote et Alexandre — idée que je répète
souvent, sur cette chaîne et ailleurs — c’est
que la culture générale permet de mieux
comprendre le monde, et que mieux comprendre
le monde permet de prendre de meilleures décisions.
C’est une évidence : on ne peut pas tout
savoir sur tout.
Ce n’est pas humainement possible, parce
qu’il y a trop de domaines et trop de connaissances
pour qu’un seul homme les maîtrise toutes.
Il faudrait à la limite être capable de
télécharger tout Wikipedia dans notre cerveau.
Et encore…
Aujourd’hui, c’est impossible — mais
dans l’Antiquité ?
Certains historiens disent d’Aristote qu’il
a été la dernière personne sur terre à
savoir tout ce que savaient les hommes de
son époque.
Alors, c’est peut-être exagéré, mais
il y a un fond de vérité.
Aristote est un exceptionnel érudit, qui
s’intéresse à tous les champs du savoir.
Il est un peu un polymathe de la Renaissance,
ou un homme des Lumières avant l’heure.
Platon le surnomme « le liseur » — et
comme si cela ne suffisait pas pour comprendre,
il appelle la maison d’Aristote « la demeure
du lecteur ».
En pratique, Aristote dépense énormément
en livres — en même temps, ce n’était
pas 0,99€ sur Amazon à l’époque — et
il est un des tous premiers à avoir une bibliothèque
dans la Grèce antique.
En quoi cette anecdote est-elle révélatrice
?
Elle révèle qu’Aristote est un des premiers
acteurs emblématiques de l’encyclopédisme
dans la civilisation occidentale.
Son effort d’érudition illustre la dimension
quantitative du progrès de la civilisation
: les accomplissements, matériels ou intellectuels,
scientifiques ou artistiques, dépendent en
partie de l’accumulation progressive des
connaissances au fil du temps, l’effort
de chaque génération s’ajoutant à celui
de la précédente.
À l’âge où l’adolescent américain
va à la High School, l’adolescent allemand
au Gymnasium, l’adolescent français va…
au lycée.
Et vous savez d’où vient le mot « lycée
» ?
Du grec Lukeion, qui est le nom du gymnase,
situé près d’Athènes, où enseignait
Aristote.
En français, on dit d’ailleurs « le Lycée
» pour désigner l’école philosophique
d’Aristote.
Il le fonde en -335 — il a alors 49 ans
— sur le modèle de l’Académie de Platon.
Il y a beaucoup d’étudiants, et d’après
les témoignages, l’ambiance est plutôt
libérale.
Comme Platon, Aristote enseigne selon la méthode
dite « péripatéticienne » : il discourt
dans une galerie du Lycée en se promenant
avec ses disciples. Le fait d’enseigner
en marchant était une pratique courante chez
les intellectuels de l’époque.
Selon certains biographes, Aristote se lêve
très tôt pour donner ses cours.
Une légende raconte qu’on lui met une boule
de bronze dans la main, au-dessus d’un bassin,
afin que, quand la boule tombe de sa main
dans le bassin, le bruit le réveille.
Mais selon d’autres biographes, c’est
l’après-midi qu’Aristote fait cours.
Alors, c’est le matin ou l’après-midi
?
Je vous donne la réponse dans la prochaine
anecdote.
Je reviens au Lycée d’Aristote : il est
inspiré de l’Académie de Platon, mais
ce n’est pas non plus une copie conforme.
La principale différence, c’est que le
Lycée est plus porté sur la biologie et
les sciences naturelles (tandis que Platon
privilégiait la métaphysique, c’est-à-dire
la philosophie hardcore, et la littérature).
Que révèle cette anecdote ?
À mes yeux, elle révèle qu’Aristote est
LUI AUSSI animé par un sentiment de rivalité
à l’égard de Platon.
Comme je l’explique dans ma vidéo sur Platon,
le maître, Platon, se sent menacé lorsqu’il
prend la mesure de l’intelligence et de
la puissance de travail du disciple, Aristote.
Mais le sentiment est réciproque : le disciple
veut surpasser le maître.
Le fait qu’il soit un des rares disciples
à contester les théories du maître en est
la preuve.
Et le fait qu’il copie l’école du maître
en est une autre.
Comment expliquer que, selon certains biographes,
les cours d’Aristote ont lieu tôt le matin,
mais que selon d’autres, ils ont lieu l’après-midi
?
Eh bien ce ne sont probablement pas les même
cours…
Je pense qu’Aristote donne ses cours ÉSOTÉRIQUES
tôt le matin, et ses cours EXOTÉRIQUES dans
l’après-midi.
L’ésotérisme, du grec ancien eso, qui
signifie « à l’intérieur » — l’ésotérisme
est la propriété d’un savoir que seuls
des initiés peuvent comprendre. Par exemple,
la mécanique quantique est un savoir ésotérique,
parce qu’il faut avoir un bon niveau en
physique pour comprendre.
L’exotérisme, du grec ancien exo, qui signifie
« hors de » — l’exotérisme est au contraire
la propriété d’un savoir que tout le monde
peut comprendre. Par exemple, l’histoire
de France est un savoir exotérique parce
que c’est simplement le récit des événements
considérés comme les plus importants dans
la mémoire collective de la nation française.
Je reviens à Aristote.
Le matin, il s’adresse à une audience restreinte
qui a un bagage intellectuel suffisant pour
comprendre des théories avancées — essentiellement
des élèves du Lycée, j’imagine.
L’après-midi, il s’adresse à une plus
large audience, et son discours tient probablement
de ce qu’on peut appeler de la vulgarisation.
Autre différence : l’après-midi, il abandonne
la méthode péripatéticienne ; il fait son
cours assis, parce que ce n’est pas possible
de parler à une foule en marchant avec elle.
En quoi cette anecdote est-elle révélatrice
?
Je trouve qu’elle est révélatrice de l’ambition
d’Aristote.
Il veut jouer sur les deux tableaux : il est
certes un théoricien qui s’adresse à l’élite
intellectuelle de son époque ; mais il veut
aussi être un vulgarisateur qui s’adresse
à un public plus large, même s’il lui
tient un discours différent.
Malheureusement, nous n’avons que l’œuvre
ÉSOTÉRIQUE d’Aristote, compilée par ses
élèves sous la forme de traités « scientifiques
» ; nous n’avons pas ses discours de vulgarisation,
qui étaient des dialogues socratiques (et
pour Platon, c’est l’inverse : nous n’avons
que ses dialogues, pas son œuvre ésotérique).
C’est en voyant Aristote passer son temps
à écrire que Platon commence à se sentir
menacé.
Effectivement, Aristote n’a pas chômé.
Il produit une œuvre immense, qui constitue
une sorte d’encyclopédie de l’époque.
Il écrit énormément de livres différents,
sur plein de sujets.
À en croire Diogène Laërce, cela représente
445 270 lignes.
J’ai un petit doute sur ce chiffre, mais
bon…
Et puis ça fait quand même beaucoup, non
?
Il y a une explication.
À un moment, Aristote se fait la même réflexion
que tous ceux qui veulent produire une grande
quantité de savoir : ça irait plus vite
à plusieurs.
Donc il commence à déléguer.
Il travaille avec des assistants de recherche,
des secrétaires et des nègres. Et puis ses
élèves ont aussi retranscrit ses cours.
Ce que révèle cette anecdote, c’est qu’Aristote,
un écrivain du IVe siècle avant J.-C., introduit
déjà la division du travail dans la production
du savoir.
On a l’image du philosophe qui est seul
avec lui-même, à lire, à réfléchir et
à écrire — mais l’œuvre d’Aristote
est un travail d’équipe.
À 61 ans, Aristote fuit Athènes en disant
: « Je ne laisserai pas deux fois pécher
contre la philosophie. »
Vous avez compris ?
Aristote fait référence à la mort de Socrate.
Souvenez-vous : Socrate avait été condamné
à boire un poison après avoir perdu son
fameux procès.
C’est ça, la première fois qu’on a pêché
contre la philosophie, selon Aristote.
Et il risque d’y avoir une deuxième fois,
car Aristote se prend à son tour le même
genre de procès — ce qu’on appelle un
« procès d’impiété » — et il sait
bien qu’il va servir de bouc émissaire
à l’opinion publique s’il se laisse faire.
Mais pourquoi lui ? Pourquoi maintenant ?
Eh bien, Alexandre le Grand vient de mourir,
donc les Athéniens sont très remontés contre
la Macédoine (à laquelle ils sont soumis
depuis 15 ans). Et comme Aristote a été
le précepteur d’Alexandre le Grand, les
Athéniens le voient un peu comme un traître.
Mais contrairement à Socrate, il ne va pas
jouer leur jeu.
Ni une ni deux, Aristote part en exil avec
sa famille à Eubée (une île près d’Athènes).
Il meurt de « vieillesse », disent les biographes,
dans la première année de sa fuite.
Il n’a que 62 ans, ce qui n’est pas si
vieux — mais c’est vrai qu’on ne coule
pas de vieux jours paisibles en fuyant la
persécution.
En quoi cette anecdote est-elle révélatrice
?
Elle révèle un schéma récurrent de l’histoire
de l’Antiquité grecque : la société qui
prend un philosophe comme bouc émissaire.
Aristote fait référence à Socrate, mais
d’autres ont subi le même sort.
C’est par exemple le cas du présocratique
Anaxagore, qui avait été le premier philosophe
à s’installer à Athènes. Il s’est pris
un procès d’impiété parce que son accusateur
estimait que sa théorie cosmique équivalait
à nier l’existence des dieux.
Par chance, Anaxagore était proche de Périclès,
qui avait suivi ses cours, donc il a eu le
temps de s’exiler — comme Aristote.
Aristote n’est pas non plus le dernier à
se prendre ce genre de procès. D’autres
philosophes grecs après lui seront accusés
d’impiété.
Et on peut même se poser la question : ce
schéma concerne-t-il uniquement la société
de l’Antiquité grecque ? Ou bien s’est-il
perpétué en Occident ?
Voilà voilà,
j’espère que cette vidéo vous a plu,
que vous avez découvert
des choses intéressantes,
et même inspirantes sur ARISTOTE.
Si c’est le cas,
donnez un pouce bleu à la vidéo,
et puis laissez un commentaire,
pour améliorer le référencement de la vidéo
— ce n’est pas grand chose,
et ça m’aide vraiment.
Vous étiez sur 1000 idées de culture générale.
Rappelez-vous
que vous n’avez PAS BESOIN
de vous prendre la tête
pour vous intéresser
au meilleur de la pensée.
________________
J’ai une question à vous poser :
vous croyez VRAIMENT
que les gens ont lu
tous les livres dont ils parlent ?
Bien sûr que non.
— sinon on ne pourrait pas parler
de grand-chose.
Eh oui,
il y a vingt-quatre heures
dans une journée,
et il faut travailler,
manger,
dormir,
et sortir le chien.
Donc le secret de la culture générale,
ce n’est PAS
de lire des livres.
C’est quoi alors ?
Eh bien en fait,
il n’y a pas qu’un seul secret,
il y en a CINQ.
Les étudiants et les personnes
les plus cultivés,
les profs,
et les intellectuels
CONNAISSENT
ces cinq secrets,
mais ils se gardent bien
d’en parler…
Les gens qui les découvrent
réussissent à développer
RAPIDEMENT
et FACILEMENT
leur culture générale,
parce que leur rapport au savoir
A CHANGÉ.
Et une fois qu’ils APPLIQUENT
les cinq secrets,
ils comprennent toutes les références
des personnes cultivées ;
ils savent s’exprimer avec profondeur
sur n’importe quel sujet ;
ils brillent par leur culture
dans les conversations
et dans les débats ;
et ils ont le recul nécessaire
pour faire preuve d’esprit critique.
Ça vous intéresse ?
Eh bien je vous révèle
les cinq secrets,
et je vous explique
comment les appliquer
DÈS AUJOURD’HUI
pour vous cultiver
DIX FOIS PLUS RAPIDEMENT
SANS VOUS PRENDRE LA TÊTE.
Pour recevoir les cinq secrets,
inscrivez-vous simplement
soit en cliquant sur le lien
qui apparaît maintenant en haut à droite
de la vidéo,
soit en cliquant sur celui
qui est dans la description
de la vidéo.
Croyez-moi :
faites-le,
et vous me remercierez.